afternoon property hi there i'm just
thinking about the property that you've
got on um
portalet road
yes oh sorry it's gone it's gone with
another agent
oh it's gone with another agent has it
sold or is it just being has it just
been
[Laughter]
oh that's annoying it was such a nice
house
that's perfect that's what i'm looking
to do i'm looking to buy them cash
buy them cash fix them up and then sell
them
yeah i've gone with another agent
i think so yeah i've just seen it online
but have you got any others have you got
any other little flips
as soon as they come in they're just
flying out to investors at the moment
i haven't got anything else to say
i put one on
it depends on the deal i'm looking for
flip so i mean i've got a few hundred
thousand cash
so it just depends on like how much how
much profit i can make but one i mean i
know i know they're few and far between
i know they sell super fast but
i mean i could go
yeah buy it and then and then sell it or
refinance it
yeah see i've got one it's 200 000
the one next sort of thing sold at 240
now it does need a full hit on it
depends on like how much you're looking
not a lot in it i mean i i'm sure you do
get
juicy deals from time to time i know
they sell real quick
i mean what what do i need to do to be
the dude that you pick up the phone to i
mean
what do you need what do you need from
me because honestly
i mean what could i possibly what could
i possibly do
you know at the moment
because you wouldn't even say to be
honest with you it's guaranteed
like a lot of people think it's just
getting the same investors it's not
i think it's just about building trust
but with someone that
the investors are you know are offering
and then
and then they're not enough time
let me give you my details give me a
shot because honestly i can move really
quick
i am i am i am busy and stuff but you
know i don't mess about and if if the
price is right i'll buy it and i'll
complete fast
so you know give me a shot if you get
something that comes up in the future
and you think it it's a good deal if it
fits just give me a shot
what's your name my name is samuel leeds
lwds
yeah like the place yeah sorry sam you
want s-a-m-u-e-l
i'm sorry that's all right you know you
can call me whatever you want as long as
you give me deals
i'm easy would you buy something without
a without hearing it well yeah i would
yeah
yeah i would
[Laughter]
new kitchen bathroom refurbished now i
think
we i've got 25 people waiting to go and
view this property
now at the moment the tenant's not
letting anybody in
because she waits for the nhs and she
said she's not accommodating anyone to
laugh a lot crowd
however some a couple of people have
been
in interested in offering honest the
vendor will take an offer on it
as long as um you know you're prepared
to offer
without seeing it and then once the
lockdown's lifted you can go in
and i have been into it it's a three-bed
expensive sunny with a garage
in a really really really good area now
i think if you've done that
or in the market at the moment
or singing and dancing you're probably
going to get around
i think about 270 40. okay just because
this
little family and how much does it need
spending on it would you how much how
much tricking you're spending on it
i think you could possibly do it for
like
15 17 grams okay
well if we if we bought it for two if we
bought it for 210 and spent 20 on it 230
in total
and then it was and we did a good refurb
and then it was worth like 270 280.
okay what i'll do because as i say i
would be happy to i'm an investor so as
long as the numbers stack i'm not too
fussed from what you've said it sounds
really good let me
let me crunch some numbers and speak and
speak to my partner and i might even
have a drive by
i know we can't go in here
so what we'd do then what we'd want to
do we'd buy it without looking at it
i mean would we be able to before we
bought it would it be able to get a
survey on it or would it would be
would the tenant not even let them this
is the problem you see
i don't know now even if you you started
the legal
sort of the legal task yeah and get some
start moving that way and then maybe get
the theory
hopefully in february yeah that's what
i'm thinking
if we got the ball rolling if we got the
ball rolling on it
and then we'd have to yeah i mean it
would just have we just have to work out
exactly what what
how it would roll because i don't mind
buying it without looking at it i've
done that many times before
but i wouldn't want to buy it so blind
that a surveyor can't even get in it
because then it could have all kinds of
problems
you know so um i mean i'd rather a
surveyor i don't if i don't go around
but a survey goes around that's better
than me going around because they know
they know more than i do
so i don't have to see it but before we
actually paid the full at full amount um
but it sounds interesting let me think
on that do you reckon then if
if i bought that place spent 15 20 grand
on it did they put hounds kitchen and it
did it nice
yeah can i be able to resell that like
270 280 back with yourselves
kitchen's fine but it just needs like
it's
because it has a big extension you see
on the back of it now which makes the
lounge side and massive at the back
now they've got it's got a big garden
which is very unusual to have a garden
egg but as well so that's why it's
getting so much attention
yeah and but it's just the stick and
point of the tenants at the moment
okay okay i'll have a little looks on
the website i'll give you a call back
thanks so much
let's go view it man let's just do a
drive-by there's so many deals there's
so many like that where though
we can't get in it yeah but we can stick
we can still go
on the outside and we can start
crunching some numbers some of these
houses are in such a bad state
we can just assume the worst and do our
calculations on the case that we have to
re-gut them
yeah but i reckon let's just go and have
a look see let's do a little drive-by